what's your favorite sports team besides
your own Miami Heat grew up a Heat fan
in South Florida and my dad rooted for
them what were your thoughts on Jimmy's
outfit he's the man so he can do
whatever he wants but wow would you ever
do that hell no what is your favorite
sport to watch football what is your
favorite reality show none of them you
had to watch one n what is your favorite
artist the weekend and lost frequencies
who is your favorite retired athlete
kangy junr what is your favorite
accessory to wear a nice watch what is
your favorite City besides this one I'm
going to go where I'm from West pal
Beach where is your favorite vacation
spot Jackson Wyoming what's the best
baseball movie of all all time s lot